Donald Trump has reportedly been
exhibiting even stranger behavior in
private going on childish tirades
against his generals including calling
them dopes and babies behind closed
doors and criticizing the United States
military as one he would not want to go
to war with this is truly stunning
there's a book coming out tomorrow
called a very stable genius Donald J
Trump's testing of America it's been
written by two authors Carol Carol lenok
and Phillip Rucker and there's an
article that's been adapted from the
book published and it's either the stuff
of a really funny political sketch
comedy show or in this case since it's
not fiction but about the real world it
is absolutely the stuff of Horrors the
incident in question happened six months
into Donald Trump's administration it's
important to remember that at the time
Jim mattis was still Secretary of
Defense no bleeding-heart liberal a
sensible guy with a worldview that does
not match mine
not a guy that will be pushed around
though and on July 20th of 2017 Donald
Trump met with secretary Jim mattis his
then Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
was also at the meeting also gone now
Gary Cohn Trump's former economic
adviser was also there also gone now and
the point of the meeting was to talk
about what is going to happen with Iran
how are we going to handle the Iran
situation Trump was already planning on
bailing on the Iran deal which he
eventually did as we now know the
meeting took place at the Pentagon
chairman of the Joint Chiefs was at the
meeting deputy defense secretary at the
meeting a lot of leaders of military
branches were at this meeting this is an
important meeting these are the generals
that we heard so much about from respect
respect for and all of that stuff they
planned the briefing with lots of maps
and pictures to try to keep Donald
Trump's attention which is always a
challenge and as soon as the meeting
started because of the tone of it and
the direction
Steve Bannon who was in the room
immediately thought this is not going to
go well Donald Trump is not going to
like this the meeting went on for 90
minutes
Trump's at attention span was like that
of a fruit fly interrupting constantly
with non sequiturs I won't list all of
Donald Trump's interruptions because
we'd be here all day but they were
really dumb
and eventually things exploded Trump
started to say other countries are
worthless NATO is worthless the
conversation kept escalating Trump said
I want out of the Iran deal it's the
worst deal in history Tillerson again
not a bleeding-heart liberal but a guy
who every once in a while would
interject some sanity into Donald
Trump's thought process Tillerson tries
to say well you know actually it's and
Trump says I don't want to hear it
they're cheating I want to get out of it
they try to talk about Iran and Trump
explodes again saying Afghanistan's
terrible that's a loser war and then
Trump attacks the generals and Trump
says you're all losers you don't know
how to win anymore and then Trump is
really in a rage and goes into personal
attack saying quote I wouldn't go to war
with you people
you're a bunch of dopes and babies
draft-dodger Trump telling a roomful of
generals that they are the dopes and the
babies everyone in the room was
reportedly stunned Tillerson was visibly
furious
madis was reportedly speechless and just
staring straight down at the table that
military thing appear apparently of this
is the commander-in-chief and I can't
really lose my mind on him but I can't
stand what's going on reportedly just
staring down at the table even Mike
Pence was reportedly silent and still
like a statue seemingly trying to blend
into the background Rex Tillerson later
said that there was a woman in the room
who was crying in a corner while this
was going on and eventually Rex
Tillerson defended the generals and
defended the military and this is the
incident that reportedly later led to
Rex Tillerson uttering that now famous
phrase that Donald Trump is a [ __ ]
which remember was sort of the beginning
of the end of Rex Tillerson
secretary ship with with Donald Trump
and a comment that he later did not deny
when given the opportunity that he
called Trump a [ __ ] so in a world that
still made sense Donald Trump voters
that claim to support the troops would
hear about this and they would be
outraged because this is not supporting
the troops this is cadet bone spurs the
mango menace this
respecting the entire military apparatus
at the highest level of course trumpets
have been so successfully primed to
believe that anything negative about
Donald Trump is fake news that it
probably will make no impact on them
whatsoever and III don't know that I
need to say this but I will I don't
agree with many of the missions of the
military I disagree with many of the
ways in which the military is deployed
but when Donald Trump who grew up with a
silver spoon in his mouth who assembles
his top generals who are people that
went to school they've had training
they've had vetting they've done
practical work they've been deployed in
many cases and Trump says I wouldn't go
to war with you guys you're dopes and
babies this is weaponized ignorance it's
weaponized narcissism and this is the
danger of Trump that he assembles his
generals as he calls them and he still
believes he knows more than them when
what they're saying doesn't go along
with his completely harebrained
preconceived notions every one of his
so-called America first supporters
should be abandoning Donald Trump over
this but it won't happen we know that it
won't because of cognitive dissonance
because of successfully priming his
followers to disbelieve anything that
sounds like Donald Trump did the wrong
thing and what you know again can we
remove the sky in November I don't know
but we damn well better try because it's
getting really really bad out there make
sure to follow me on Twitter at D Pakman
if you want to see how bad it's getting
check out my hate mail post from this
morning follow me at D Pakman and let me
know what you think about this latest
report